- [Narrator:] Once every generation...
a new star arrives.
- [Spaceship:] Undesirable destination confirmed.
- [Laughing] C'est super.
- [Narrator:] And everyone prepares for him.
- Shaquillum O'Nealus!
- [Narrator:] He can turn another young star
into a second fiddle.
He can build somethin'
out of all those bricks you've been pilin' up.
He can restart a fanbase's engine.
And finally answer...
all your tough questions.
He can even stop the greedy from hoardin'.
And maybe,
just maybe, he could stop our drought.
- Bonjour!
Which lucky souls has won the Wemby lottery?
- [Gregg Popovich:] And if he doesn't land here...
I mean, I’ll take a flier Scoot. I don't care.
I’m gonna live forever.